[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia el 7 de noviembre de 2021
nicaragua elige presidente unos comicios
en los cuales la oposición espera
relevar democráticamente del poder a
daniel ortega a quien acusa de dictador
y opresor un objetivo complicado
teniendo en cuenta que ortega buscará
reelegirse a toda costa para un cuarto
mandato consecutivo de cinco años
empresa para la cual no ha escatimado en
reformas políticas que lo legitimen y en
arrestos de adversarios incluidos siete
candidatos presidenciales un clima de
extrema atención política al que le
antecede en los años más convulsos por
los que ha atravesado nicaragua desde
que el país centroamericano encarnó una
guerra civil en la década de 1980 el
estallido social del 18 de abril de 2018
que comenzó con una protesta de
pensionados en contra de unas reformas
al sistema de seguridad social derivó en
un mes de masivas manifestaciones que
dejaron en claro el arte
de miles de personas hacia el gobierno
de ortega el mismo gobierno que reprimió
con violencia las protestas por las
cuales murieron más de 300 ciudadanos y
miles resultaron heridos así que nos
preguntamos quién es daniel ortega un
antiguo revolucionario que luchaba
contra la tiranía y crueldad de un
dictador pero que ahora se ha investido
de la misma figura que combatía para
desentrañar la figura de ortega es
preciso remontarse a la década de 1970
la última en que la dinastía somoza
estuvo en el poder nicaragüense tres de
ellos padre y dos hijos gobernaron con
mano de hierro durante 42 años bajo el
signo de la inequidad y el sometimiento
del pueblo con el aval de eeuu pero
antonio somos a el último del clan
familiar en estar a cargo fue el más
cruel según mónica valdo tanweer
historiadora y ex comandante del frente
sandinista de liberación nacional
somoza dirigió operaciones de genocidio
contra el pueblo nicaragüense una vez
que éste se insurreccionó de modo que
lanzó bombas a las ciudades
su conducta perdió el respaldo de eeuu
si en cuba la revolución de fidel castro
había logrado derrocar del poder al
dictador fulgencio batista porque no
sucedería lo mismo en nicaragua en parte
con esta inspiración nació el partido
frente sandinista de liberación nacional
en 1961 fundado por carlos fonseca como
una organización militar de izquierda
que tomó su nombre de augusto sandino
aquel guerrillero que a comienzos del
siglo 20 luchó contra la intervención
estadounidense en nicaragua entre las
filas del frente sandinista estaba el
joven guerrillero daniel ortega el
revolucionario participó de varias
operaciones de los sandinistas hasta que
en 1967 fue puesto preso por el robo a
un banco que le costaron torturas y
siete años de prisión pero en 1974 un
comando sandinista que secuestro a altos
funcionarios de somoza logró
intercambiarlo y exiliarlo mientras
ortega estaba en costa rica los
sandinistas con el apoyo del pueblo
avanzaron una lucha armada en el campo y
en las ciudades
con varios focos de insurrección entre
1978 y 1979 habiendo perdido el apoyo de
eeuu y con un cerco de los países
vecinos a somoza no le quedó otra que
huir del país un año después fue
asesinado en asunción paraguay
los revolucionarios sandinistas entraron
a managua el 19 de julio de 1979 y
formaron una junta de gobierno de
reconstrucción nacional para la cual
repatriaron a daniel ortega dicha junta
tenía la misión de reconstruir un país
sumido en la pobreza y la desesperanza
habían muerto alrededor de 50.000
personas en la guerra contra somos a la
infraestructura estaba en ruinas y el
país le debía al extranjero una deuda de
1600 millones de dólares
los años siguientes fueron de intensas
reformas revolucionarias para favorecer
a los más pobres nacionalización de
industrias y de la banca reforma agraria
y reforma de educación entre otros
avances en este contexto los sandinistas
celebraron elecciones generales en 1984
y el candidato del frente
sandinista daniel ortega ganó los
comicios y se hizo presidente pero a la
sombra de la revolución crecía un
proyecto de contra revolución de
antiguos militares de la guardia
nacional apoyados una vez más por eeuu
según la historiadora valdo tano con la
llegada al poder en washington de ronald
reagan se inauguró un periodo de
agresión violenta contra la revolución
la cual fue asfixia no sólo militar sino
económicamente en efecto tras el bloqueo
impuesto por reagan en 1981 contra una
ya decadente economía nicaragüense más
la violencia entre los revolucionarios y
la contra el frente sandinista en 1990
perdió las elecciones así concluye un
período revolucionario de 11 años de
1979 a 1990
ortega empecinado en retomar el poder
siguió liderando el frente sandinista y
se presentó fallidamente en otras
elecciones presidenciales hasta que en
2007 volvió a ser elegido como el líder
de los nicaragüenses con el paso de los
años construyó un proyecto en el cual se
sirvió
modificar la constitución para poder
reelegirse su gobierno ha sido acusado
de corrupción y de cometer graves
violaciones de derechos humanos su
matrimonio con rosario murillo ahora
vicepresidenta del país se consolidó
como una dupla temida que tiene asumido
en nicaragua en una profunda crisis
ahora el país se apresta para unas
elecciones presidenciales bajo denuncias
de asedio y persecución política en las
cuales varias fórmulas opositores
quieren arrebatarle el poder a ortega y
evitar que se perpetúe su mandato así
concluimos soy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]